we've been in our YouTube Secrets series
here on the think media podcast and we
did a two-part series on the seven C's
of YouTube success and now we're headed
into a four-part series on the perfect
video recipe
um you know the Seven Seas of YouTube
success include the C content and really
at the end of the day content is most
important on YouTube content is King if
you're not making great videos you're
gonna lose on YouTube and so the
question is how do I make great videos
and that's where we designed the perfect
video recipe and what I love about it is
if you don't have a recipe let's say
when you're in the kitchen cooking you
might end up with something good but you
probably won't I don't know about you I
mean you may be already a world-class
chef and and you can just kind of make
things up and it turns out great but
I've found that if I don't follow the
recipe and I just start throwing random
ingredients into the bowl I don't know
what temperature to set the oven I'm not
really sure how long it should even be
in there I end up with some burnt
chicken I end up with it's way too much
salt you know I end up you serve it to
your family members and they are like
what just happened we are gonna order
ubereats or doordash you know what I
mean and so the power of having a recipe
it means it takes some of the uh the
pressure off of having to know
everything about YouTube just follow the
recipe and that's why we designed this
now after studying thousands of viral
videos posting
um thousands of my own videos over 200
million video views that my content has
gotten and now I've helped tens of
thousands of people implement this
recipe it's really been refined down to
serve you and help and in this first
ingredient we're talking all about the
big idea I'll give you all four of the
ingredients and that's going to be
happening over the next four episodes
um on the think media podcast they may
not all be in order but we'll make sure
they're labeled uh like PVR part one two
three and four in the uh and at least on
the audio episodes so you can kind of
find this whole series and this is the
perfect video recipe one the big idea
two the hook three content and four the
transition today we're going to be
talking about the big idea and this is
one of the biggest mistakes that most
creators make what they do is that they
press record ultimately before having a
plan now I just want to address the
elephant in the room because if you
follow my content very closely then you
might think Sean you're a contradiction
well on the one hand you just tell us
you gotta just press record and you got
to start before you're ready and then
you say but actually wait don't do that
actually make a plan actually like make
sure things are and which one do you
mean do you mean start or do you mean
sit down and plan I actually mean both I
actually really believe there's a place
and a time and a time and a place
to actually just punch fear in the face
and start no plan not overthinking it
grab your smartphone and that's usually
your first few videos because I found
people get stuck in analysis paralysis
they get stuck in constantly learning
and not doing and we have to be
implementing in fact I think we learn
best when we take action we learn best
by posting videos on YouTube and
studying not just studying because once
you're posting you can start getting
some momentum but you also start
understanding what you're learning
better you go oh yeah now I understand
why that last video didn't do very good
um that's right I've posted three videos
now and now what Sean's saying is making
sense because I'm noticing I missed out
on on that tip so this perfect video
recipe you you may not do it perfectly
the first time you may be like I
completely forgot the Cajun spices I was
supposed to put there in the beginning
it still turned out all right but I I
just I didn't I missed that ingredient
the goal is to have a recipe to follow
so you've got the ingredients the right
things in the right order and it starts
with the big idea and where a lot of
times creators struggle is they don't
start with the big idea first what's the
big idea it's three things what is the
topic of my video what is the title of
my video and what is the thumbnail of my
video
now here's the secret
you actually want to get clear on these
things
before you even record the video
because the more clarity you have on
what the thumbnail is and what the title
is the better informed you will be when
creating the video itself so that
everything aligns one of the worst
things you can do is get to the end you
film you shoot you sit down you go all
right so what exactly is this video even
about what should the title be and it's
kind of hard to come up with the title
because you're not even sure you don't
have you don't have Clarity ahead of
time what should the thumbnail be when
you actually study great
some of the biggest most influential
creators you study someone like a Mr
Beast they won't even make a video
unless they love the title and thumbnail
they make ahead of time he'll sometimes
spend hundreds even thousands of dollars
to design a thumbnail like you'll build
a set and get on a ladder and take a
picture of him you know in a coffin
because he did this video called like
being buried alive or whatever and and
he will actually take the thumbnail
think about what the title is which
essentially is thinking about the topic
itself and then say Wow Let's green
light that project let's actually make
that video now and here's why coming up
with the big idea first is so important
is you're asking yourself is this video
even worth making like should I even
create this video you know do people
care about this topic and how strong is
this idea
you know if you really think about it
for most of our niches meaning most of
our Channel topics
if we were going to create a YouTube
video we have
thousands tens of thousands of options
about what we can make that video about
like you're gonna film a video tomorrow
and even in any Niche like if you were
in real estate you could talk about
loans you could talk about you could do
a walkthrough of a house in your
neighborhood you could do a review of
the restaurants in your city you could
talk about the market you could talk
about interest rates you could talk
about how to quali like so so there's
like a million things you could talk
about if you were making skits different
things you could do if you were you know
like and so there's so many different
ideas the big question is am I coming up
with a topic that's worth making and
what I find that a reason that a lot of
people struggle is they're making the
wrong ideas they're just they're they're
they they've posted 50 videos
but like those aren't the best videos to
be posting like even what the video is
about so before you get to the content
before you make a thumbnail or a title
whatever topic is one of your biggest
levers for ultimately starting to get
traction on YouTube
you know one of the examples that uh
kind of illustrates this is what's
called
um the log line and this is a YouTube
secret I learned from Hollywood movies
so when a movie is going to be made
there's something like hundreds of
thousands of scripts that get submitted
to Hollywood Studios per year
but actually only a couple hundred end
up getting made
and that's kind of what the YouTube
Creator goes through there's hundreds of
thousands of videos you could make but
there's probably only a hundred you
should make this year that's going to be
the best return on investment of your
energy your time your emotions your
money whatever and so what the
scriptwriters will do is they come up
with a log a log line which is a one
sentence summary of of a description of
a movie and what it does is it distills
down the important elements of your
screenplay the main character the setup
the central conflict the antagonist into
a clear and concise teaser examples of a
log line is like the movie Elf did you
love that movie a Christmas elf goes to
New York City that's the log line how
about the Matrix a computer hacker
learns from mysterious Rebels about the
true nature of his reality and his role
in the war against its controllers how
about The Lion King
you know Akuma Matata right here's the
log line lion cub and Future King Simba
searches for his identity his eagerness
to please others and his penchant for
testing boundaries sometimes gets him in
trouble Sean what does this have to do
with making a YouTube video it's the
idea that before Hollywood is going to
put millions of dollars behind a movie
a lighting crew a gaff team before
they're going to scout locations buy
plane tickets develop costumes invest
you know energy in lighting and gear and
cameras and then the editing and and all
the marketing
they determine if they even want to make
the movie at all and most of the scripts
summarized in the log line actually end
on The Cutting Room floor
now I understand that you making YouTube
videos is not at the same scale as The
Amazing Spider-Man with really big CGI
Graphics you know what I mean but I
still want to acknowledge that you've
got a family to lead you've got a
business to run you have limited time so
you getting up taking a shower getting
your whiteboard out teaching something
researching for a video studying for a
video it takes energy so you don't want
to just spread that energy across a
bunch of videos you shouldn't even be
making you don't want to spread that
energy across ideas that aren't even
worth investing in so your goal just the
log line idea is thinking about and
here's the action item brainstorm 20
YouTube video ideas like what are just
20 ideas you could make that would be
decent but then narrow it down to the
one or two that would have the biggest
amount of impact the most amount of
people be interested in them what's the
Hollywood movie think will people even
buy tickets for this will we watch get
our money back
will we actually get a return on our
investment
is there going to be enough interest in
this movie is there going to be enough
desire for people to attend well people
share this with their friends is this
what people care about right now is this
what people want to watch right now
and maybe it's maybe you're like wow
it's going to be really good though the
information is going to be amazing I
know a lot about this like those are all
things that might indicate that you want
to make the YouTube video but you're
asking yourself will the YouTube video
be successful
this is why the big idea is the first
ingredient and this is why it's so
important to spend time on really
thinking about the topic excuse me no
don't cut the burp out to think about
the thumbnail and to think about the
title you know your title is kind of
like the title of a movie your thumbnail
is kind of like the movie poster it's
marketing for the big idea itself and if
we take it back to the perfect video
recipe cooking analogy it's also like
thinking about you might be the best
cook in the world you make the best meal
in the world you actually are great with
the ingredients you're great with uh the
the cooking time and and everything is
done right and it's presented right but
if it's the wrong type of food for the
market you're in
then no one is going to ultimately be
interested in it so it's kind of like if
you were to uh trying to want you want
to open up a new restaurant in a certain
town you maybe want to ask yourself is
there enough of the demographics that
would want to eat that type of food even
in the town doesn't matter if the
content is good if the big idea is wrong
if it's in the wrong place if it's at
the wrong time so so not a lot of people
talk about this and this is a big
mistake a lot of people make they're
making the wrong videos they're
literally not making videos about the
right topics this is why we devote in in
part two of our online course called
video record Academy called VRA Masters
we go into 16 different video types
video ideas and types of videos that
most creators don't even understand
because you got to be actually making
the right you know again you put all
your money about it behind it all your
energy you spend a whole week in filming
videos you were making the wrong videos
and they may have been great but they
were the wrong topic people didn't care
about the topic the title wasn't right
like the the whole idea itself wasn't
right so the Big Ideas ultimately
coming up with a strong topic a strong
title and a strong thumbnail which leads
to a strong click-through rate the CTR
is what you want this is what's going to
trigger the YouTube algorithm it's going
to get you a good click-through rate and
it's not unlike Netflix think about your
click-through rate on Netflix you're on
there you're on Hulu right now right and
you're clicking through and you're
looking at the thumbnails and the titles
you're like nah I don't want to watch
that no I don't want to watch that if
you're skipping over it you're skipping
over it millions of dollars have been
poured into those videos you're skipping
over you know actors have been hired
locations have been scouted and you're
just in four seconds while you're eating
popcorn and chocolate ice cream are
skipping over millions of dollars of
people's work on your Netflix screen why
because you don't care about the topics
if you see a topic and it's a movie you
want to see you're like that's the one
for me and it gets your click and if
it's something a lot of people want to
see then the click-through rate goes up
again that might be a new metric for you
if you're new to YouTube But ultimately
before someone can even watch your
content they have to click on your video
the title and the thumbnail are going to
influence that but the Topic's going to
influence that even more do you even
care about the subject matter is it a
compelling idea that grips your
attention
and so the first ingredient of the
perfect video recipe is the big idea and
if you want to learn more about this
inside of my book YouTube secrets we go
in depth on the perfect video recipe
it's one of the new chapters and um it's
a very powerful chapter and one of the
things that I like to do is I don't just
study to learn I like to study so that I
never forget
and I've learned that repetition is the
father of learning and the mother of
Mastery and as you master the perfect
video recipe you're gonna see your
results on YouTube Skyrocket and think
about it like this when you go to the
kitchen and if you're new to cooking
like me then then you definitely don't
Master every dish but I just keep
showing up I just try to get a little
bit better every time I try to cook for
my family I just try to get a little bit
better with not turning the heat on too
high when I'm making my son Shawn
Bradley's eggs you don't want to go on
full heat when you're doing scrambled
eggs the lower the heat right you don't
overcook the eggs you get them nice
fluffy not overcooked I had to learn
that by doing it over and over and
making those eggs not very good luckily
as a two-year-old he doesn't actually
discriminate that much but when I sample
his eggs I can tell that they're
sometimes good and sometimes they're
over cooked but here's what I learned is
I just got to keep showing up in the
kitchen I just got to keep cooking and
the same thing is true about YouTube use
the perfect video recipe but don't
overthink it just get one percent better
with every upload get one percent better
identifying powerful topics identifying
powerful titles I you know coming up and
designing powerful thumbnails and as you
keep using the recipe and as you keep
improving your skills your views are
going to go up your subscribers are
going to go up and ultimately your
impact is going to go up today's episode
is brought to you by ytsecrets.com for
more on this check it out in the book
and also if you've already picked up a
copy of the book it's on Audible it's on
the audiobook is on Audible The ebook is
on Kindle and then and everything's on
Amazon but at ytsecrets.com we have some
other cool stuff to check out so you can
see all of that in the show notes and if
you've checked out the book it would
mean the world to me if you left a
review on Amazon listen I know you're
driving right now I know you're you know
watching this you're multitasking right
now you're doing something else but my
friend if I've added any value to you on
this podcast or on YouTube over the the
years it would seriously like make the
biggest difference if you just took two
minutes to go to Amazon that is if
you've bought the book and you've
actually read it you've listened to it
and you leave an Amazon review for
authors it's it means the world it
really helps and it also really gives me
feedback about what you think about the
content in the book here's what I know
this book will add more value to you
than what you pay for it the Kindle is
like five bucks the physical books under
15. you can get the audiobook for free
if you don't have an audible account or
it's just like one credit and after you
check it out if it's terrible let me
know leave me a review and let me know
that but I really believe this book is
going to help you go further faster on
YouTube and I can't wait to see you or
to be connecting with you on audio on
the next think media podcast
foreign